cette confusion en Russie aura-t-elle
aussi des conséquences sur la guerre en
Ukraine difficile à dire pour l'instant
sur le front en tout cas l'Ukraine
revendique plusieurs avancées même la
libération d'un village dans la région
de donnetz qu'une équipe de France
Télévisions s'est rendue dans la région
de saporizia où elle reportage de Maryse
Burgot d'Alban mikosi et de Bruno
Giraudeau
les forces ukrainiennes au combat hier
après-midi sur le front de zapporijah
la fenêtre d'opportunité créée par les
événements samedi en Russie a été très
courte
l'armée de Kiev espère pourtant en
profiter pour déstabiliser l'ennemi les
soldats en repos en ville sont dans cet
état d'esprit
j'espère que ça va générer une forme de
panique sur le front que leur morale
leur envie de combattre va baisser en
vérité je ne comprends pas quel est leur
motivation pour mener cette guerre
pour le moment c'est trop tôt pour
mesurer les effets réels sur le terrain
peut-être que ça va réduire leur nombre
il faut attendre
même état d'esprit chez les civils
je pense que ça ne va pas changer
grand-chose
les Russes ne se retireront pas
volontairement
je ne crois pas que la guerre puisse
s'achever rapidement en tout cas
ça va réduire la pression j'espère en
tout cas peut-être moins de
bombardements sur nos villes et sur
notre armée
un peu de
tranquillité
pas de frappe russe
se
sur le front de barmouth là où on
combattu les hommes de Wagner les
Ukrainiens ont légèrement progressé ces
derniers jours
600 à 900 mètres de territoire repris
sur les flancs nord
issus de cette ville la rébellion avorté
de prigogines va-t-elle durablement
entamer le moral des soldats russes
c'est en tout cas ce qu'espère les
autorités de Kiev